yes sorry random adolescent youth in
this movie you're still not more
hardcore than Sarah from labyrinth
because whereas you guys had to take on
biomechanical scorpion spiders in this
movie she had to take on the bony bone
and no one wins against the Bowie bulge
it wins every time The Maze Runner so
The Maze Runner is a movie starring all
adolescent youth everyone in this field
that's surrounded by a huge maze they
don't know why they're there all their
memories are gone then a new guy gets
there and of course now shit's gonna get
real cuz he's gonna be like why are we
all settling for this [ __ ] let's find a
way out of here some people like it some
people don't it causes some conflict it
causes some hope point is we now have a
movie it's actually a pretty
entertaining be it pretty imperfect
movie yeah the movie has flaws for sure
especially when you get out of the movie
you start thinking about it you're like
yeah that didn't make sense but you have
a good time you acting in the movie for
the most part pretty good the little
brat kid from voyage of the Dawn Treader
he's in this movie he's the big militant
guy who to thought who'd have thought
the little whiny brat from the Narnia
movie grew up to be sergeant eyebrows
what he is he's trying to maintain order
in this place like let's not change the
game and the main dudes like let's
change the game in the game gets changed
when a female also arrived someone
didn't think this [ __ ] through oh is
somebody like hey that may is complete
sausage fest of dudes all adolescents
some of them haven't seen a female in
years let's send one female up where
there are no consequences among them
they can drop rocks on piggies head they
can commit really heinous sexual crimes
if they want yeah let's send a chick up
there makes sense the point is I like
the tone of this movie I like the fact
that you know everyone is essentially in
a cage this big field you know it has a
habitat of sorts to it they have a
forest in the corner even for the most
part it's just it's a field in the
middle of this huge maze you look around
360 degrees just a big walls like a big
wall of ice in the north you know in
Westeros and [ __ ] is like that but it's
big in metal and the doors of this maze
will open and people will run it in the
daytime they'll try to map it out but if
they get caught in there at night the
doors are closed and then really huge
biomechanical scorpions will kill them
not only do you really get the confined
feeling that people are cut off from the
outside ropes you don't know what the
world you don't know where they are who
has them in this maze people is it
aliens what I saw Dark City this [ __ ]
could turn really nuts really fast all
you see is this field in the middle of
the maze and you feel really isolated
and I like that because you're supposed
to feel that way and this movie has more
than a few really intense chase scenes
in a movie called The Maze Runner I want
that you're like make it all go okay oh
man that was an intense scene oh [ __ ]
that's my hand now as I came to see that
in this movie and that movie delivered
that this movie does drop the ball and
believability though for sure I was
looking forward to this movie being like
a Lord of the Flies type movie you know
where it's like Oh order where is it
it's not seriously if these youth were
left to their own devices to construct
their own civilization in here they'd be
screwed they do illustrate that that
kind of was a phase they went through
but I just don't think that phase would
end
maybe I watched too much Walking Dead to
have faith in humanity but I'm just
saying I just think it would go that way
this movie doesn't keep the intrigue
alive for too long I start showing you
glimpses and things that let you piece
together it's not even a piece together
thing it's like oh you showed me that
now I at least know that the world
operates in this realm
and speaking of Ko because i don't want
to spoil it for you but i'm just saying
the first couple of glimpses you're like
okay i generally know where this is
going now I wish they kept you isolated
didn't show any glimpses no memories
whatsoever and then you can show it in
the end it just kind of looking you add
it's crazy which I guess would be
idealistic if the ending was good at all
the endings terrible it's [ __ ] no
seriously it's one of those endings that
the more you think about it when you're
driving home the worst it gets the
ending is like a thread and you keep
pulling on it it just unravels the
entire course of the story and then
you're like ah the story is just a Ravel
on the floor because it makes no sense
because the ending completely
deconstructed all of it and made it all
irrelevant because the ending makes no
sense whatsoever it's one of those
things where I was like I that doesn't
make sense for that I'm not gonna spoil
the ending for you but honestly a better
ending it would be this they get out of
this maze and then they see it they see
George Takei he's just like hello you've
all been running the maze to answer one
very important question do people really
hate the McRib oh my and that would be
it and you'd be like oh that's stupidest
[ __ ] it's better than the real ending in
the end The Maze Runner it's implausible
it doesn't make sense but they do a good
job at isolating you and you're rooting
for these people to you know make it out
of this maze or find their answers it
doesn't keep intrigue alive too long
because of these flashbacks I'd like to
see a cut of the movie with
just take out the flashbacks it has
really intense moments it was exciting
in parts and even if it's not exciting
even when they're just talking it's all
about the environment man it has a good
environment but the ending [ __ ] just
leave 10 minutes before the movie ends
you'll be fine and I will still say The
Maze Runner is still a good time no
alcohol required oh by God willing to
make a sequel who knows maybe with 3d
being the craze right now they'll call
it 3d world run you remember that game
holy [ __ ] I played the [ __ ] out of that
game didn't it Dana no no no no no don't
no no no no no no no no the Maze Runner
have you seen it what did you think
about it or ever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you
wanna see more click right here to see
more